And the first thing I want to say is
that there's a thesis to the course that,
um, you don't have to share, but that
I'd like to test for the next, uh,
12 or 13 weeks and not thesis is that
infectious diseases are too important to
leave solely to the doctors.
Epidemics,
in other words,
have had an impact on history that
I would regard as equal to that of
revolutions,
wars and economic crises.
They are part of the big picture of
historical change and not some exotic
special interest.
Epidemic diseases have had an
enormous impact on religion,
on the arms,
on the colonial expansion,
on the establishment of new world slavery,
on the rise of modern medicine and
on strategies of public health.
To examine this thesis,
we won't be looking at all diseases.
We'll be looking only at a subset of
high impact infectious diseases that have
affected Europe and North America.
So this means certain exclusions.
We won't be looking at chronic
diseases such as cancer,
heart disease, diabetes, asthma, obesity.
We won't be examining
occupational diseases such as
miner's lung or asbestosis.
We'll eliminate also a whole range of
tropical diseases that haven't had a major
impact on the industrial west such as
Dang gay or sleeping sickness or chagas
disease.
All of these and other diseases I would
agree entirely aren't important and
worthy of study,
but it would take far more than a semester
to examine the mall and lumping all
diseases together would lose
all coherence epidemic diseases.
That is our high impact.
Infectious diseases make sense
intellectually as a separate category of
analysis.
That is to say they were and still are
experienced differently from chronic
disease and give rise to
distinctive fears and anxiety.
As you can see on your own day.
Having heart disease can be frightening
and an even a lethal experience,
but it's qualitatively distinct
from being diagnosed with HIV AIDS
or up to the middle of our century with
syphilis or being stricken with Asiatic
cholera.
Cardiovascular disease with can have
massive impact but it doesn't give rise to
escape Gooding to mass hysteria,
to outbursts of religiosity to
works of literature and art.
So epidemic diseases are distinctive and
have left a particular legacy in their
way.
And since our interest is in history,
we need to know that throughout human
history until the 20th century and still
today and the 20th first
century in the developing world,
infectious diseases have been the most
important cause of suffering and death.
Infectious diseases today are the
leading cause worldwide of death.
And one of the jobs of our force is to
give an explanation of why that song.
Furthermore,
we've had a number of recent
scares from new diseases like SARS,
avian flu,
swine flu.
We're living in the midst of a global,
uh,
experience with the persistence of HIV,
AIDS,
tuberculosis,
malaria.
And these events remind us that epidemics
is still major threats even in the
industrial world.
Indeed,
how we deal with them may be an important
factor and whether and how we survive
as a species.
So the course will raise the question
of how prepared we are today.
What are our major defenses
against microbial disasters?
How did they evolve,
how robust are they,
and what are the most important
sources of vulnerability today?
Well. Then let's think about
geography of our course.
Our focus will be primarily on York and
North America and I wish to say entirely
for reasons of manageability
and you'll be grateful because,
um,
if we attempted to include the whole of
the world throughout the period and all
tropical diseases,
you'd have a reading list that would be
four or five times as long as the one
you have.
But I would also say that we,
when we come to the 20th and 21st century
and deal with such global pandemics is
HIV, aids, malaria and tuberculosis.
We will look quickly a
little further a field,
it would be perverse to discuss HIV
aids without paying attention to Africa,
which has its place of origin,
its epicenter,
and the place where the disease is
causing almost an unimaginable burdens of
suffering and loss.
We're in escapable,
he part of a global world in which
microbes refused to recognize political
borders and we have to take that into,
so that's the geography focusing
on Europe and North America,
but branching out for the very
modern part of the course.
Chronology. Uh, when,
what period do we cover?
Well really we look at the
centuries from 1600 to the present.
We'll start with everyone's idea of the
worst case scenario in terms of epidemic
disease.
And by that I mean boob onic plague and
we'll end with the current situation and
the latest threats to
have emerged like SARS,
avian flu and swine flu.
As a student,
I always felt disappointed when history
classes on the modern period didn't come
right up today.
So I feel a motivation
to bring us up to uh,
the newspapers today.
In fact,
one of the goals of the class is to help
to equip ourselves with the critical
tools we need to confront today's
events in a more informed and productive
manner.
And since I've mentioned influenza,
we'll certainly ask in passing.
And I hope some of you will answer the
question why it is that the most Penn
threatening pandemic afflictions of
the 21st century seem to be respiratory
diseases.
Why is that?
How did that come to bout then I want
to talk with you for a couple of minutes
about the diseases that we'll be
examining. I've told you so far,
the ones we mostly won't be looking at.
Well first,
what are the criteria by
which I've chosen them?
First I'm going to be looking at epidemic
diseases that had the greatest social,
scientific and cultural effects.
We'll call them high
impact infectious diseases.
That's the first criteria,
their impact. Second,
I'll be looking at diseases that have
had the most important role in the
development of public health
strategies to consent them.
A major concern throughout the course
is the variety of efforts that societies
have made to prevent,
contain,
cure and eradicate infectious diseases
are courses not only about disease but
also about public health.
And so we'll give that a privileged
place to that and to those diseases that
stimulated various styles of organized
and effective societal responses.
Uh,
next criterion is that we're going to
look at those diseases that were the most
feared killers of each of the
centuries that we'll study.
We'll also want a very
diet and in other words,
diversity.
And to that end,
some of our diseases will be some viral,
some parasitic,
some will be transmitted sexually,
some through the air,
others through food.
And Water and some are carried by insects
and by these criteria will focus in
particular on bubonic plague,
on Asiatic cholera,
smallpox, syphilis, tuberculosis,
polio,
HIV AIDS and yellow fever with
influenza bringing us right up to date,
so those are the diseases we'll
be concentrating on. Well,
how do we deal with them?
What's our strategy?
What's our way forward and I want to
stress that this is not a biology course,
but a history course.
Epidemic diseases are biological
events and we'll need to have some
understanding of what they are,
where they come from,
how they were transmitted,
how they affect the human body.
It would be inconceivable to study the
history of medicine without coming to
terms with the medical and
biological aspects of disease.
Indeed,
one of our goals will be to examine
major changes and medical thinking and
philosophy,
but the biology will be throughout in
the background and the exams and the
papers will not test you specifically
on that aspect of the course.
Our concern will be with the
impact of disease on society,
religion and culture,
but we want to do a lot more than
examine a series of gas leak,
biological invaders,
although we will do that and so the
course will stress a number of longterm
themes. The first of those I've already
told you about and that's public health
strategies.
We'll look at vaccination as a strategy,
quarantine and sanitary cordons,
urban cleanups and sanitary movements,
Santa Turia as for tuberculosis,
magic bullets like Quinine,
penicillin, antibiotics,
and we'll also look at an unfortunate
public health policy by which I mean
concealment to hide the presence of
disease as China did during SARS,
but following a long precedent in which
other governments have a history of
adopting similar policies and
we'll be looking at that too.
Then we'll be looking at intellectual
history, epidemic diseases.
In other words,
had a leading role in the development
of the modern biomedical paradigm of
disease with the germ theory and such
disciplines is tropical medicine and
infectious diseases.
And I'll want to argue,
or at least we'll be testing the
idea that perhaps medical ideas,
one of their aspects is that their
ideologies held not only for scientific
reasons,
although that's true,
but also because of the kinds of societies
they promote or the power they convey
to nations or strategically
placed elites within them.
That will be a question
we'll be examining.
Then we'll be looking at ethical issues.
Uh,
what are the ethics if
human experimentation and
we'll be looking at some
horrific failures and ethical standards
and in particular we'll examine the
Tuskegee syphilis study.
We'll also be looking and thinking about
diseases as a tool for the historian as
a means of casting,
revealing light on how societies are
constructed on the relations if human
beings to one another on
the moral priorities of
statesmen and religious leaders
on the relationship of human
beings with their environment.
By which I mean both the natural
environment and the built environment,
the cities in particular
in which they live.
So responses to epidemic
diseases will be important to us.
How do people respond?
And we'll be looking at stigmatization,
witch hunting and scapegoating at flight
and mass hysteria at up surges and rela
jaw city at changes in
art and in philosophy
the course.
We'll also try to provide
some understanding of a
number of major concepts and
terminology and public health.
By the end of the class,
you should be fluent in
using words like etiology,
case fatality rate,
no zoology,
and you should know the difference between
incidence and prevalence between an
epidemic and a pandemic between
inoculation and vaccination.
And then another theme will
be an assessment, as I said,
of where we stand today
and the 21st century.
What have we learned as a society from
the experience of the past four centuries
of recurring and dreadful epidemics
in 1969 the US surgeon general,
how to premature surge of optimism and
the age of antibiotics and he declared as
he put it,
we've turned the page on infectious
disease and medical schools and the public
health community talk,
but it would be possible to eradicate
one epidemic disease after another like
smallpox or polio as models.
But our surgeon general turned out to
be spectacularly wrong today in 2010
infectious diseases or the number
one cause of death worldwide.
And it's also clear that it
will be impossible to write
the history of the 20th
and 21st century without giving you a
central place at the very least to HIV,
aids and to other pandemics as well.
Furthermore,
we know too that there's a whole hearse
host of emerging diseases of Bola,
Lassa fever, West Nile
virus, SARS, avian flu aids,
and of course swine flu and familiar
diseases have reemerged and resistant and
threatening manners such as drug resistant
tuberculosis or malaria and other
diseases as well.
So the threat has been made clear and
dress rehearsals we've had in our new
century SARS, avian flu, and as we speak,
swine flu and indeed the nature of modern
society may make us more vulnerable
rather than less to such.
Threats will want to think about some
of the factors that may make that true
such as a high and ever growing world.
Population density as we rapidly reach
a figure of 7 billion people before very
long rapid movements of
population by rail road,
cruise ship,
but above all the airplane,
rapid and chaotic urbanization with the
appearance of evermore mega cities with
populations in excess of 10
million people, places like Tokyo,
Mexico City, Lagos, Delhi,
Mumbai, New York, Jacarda,
whiteness,
Iris and others.
These many of them conjure
up images of overcrowding,
of poverty,
substandard housing,
inadequate access to healthcare,
extensive illiteracy,
open sewers.
Then there's the perennial problem of
warfare and the terrible dislocations that
wars leave in their wig,
displaced people, refugee camps,
the collapse of health
systems and sanitation,
extensive poverty and
widening social inequalities,
climatic change and
environmental devastation and
the failure to provide such
basics as safe and adequate water supplies
for untold millions of people in the
developing world.
Unfortunately not one of those factors
seems likely to abate and then your
future and some of them are
gathering momentum as we speak.
Well,
it's possible and reasonable even to
ask that the way whether it is true that
the way we handle epidemic diseases
will be crucial to our survival as a
society.
In addition,
I would argue that it's important
to examine these diseases,
the ones that have been most prevalent
as they hold up a mirror to ourselves.
I would argue that every s diseases and
epidemic disease in particular aren't.
These are not random events that every
society has its own specific types of
affliction and to study them is to
learn about it's living conditions.
It's more a priorities and
relationships for all of these reasons.
We could argue that epidemic diseases
are great bearers of meaning,
and our job is to decipher the meaning
embedded in them as contemporaries
experienced them and to
understand them retrospectively.
Well then that brings us to our first
couple of weeks and where we go next.
Well,
on Wednesday we'll roll up our sleeves
and get down to work looking at the
meanings that Europeans gave to epidemic
diseases when they first stroke a
continent and as they were seeing
through the lens of the reigning medical
doctrine.
That is the humoral lessem philosophy
developed by Hippocrates and Galen at the
time of plague in the 17th century,
humoral ism,
which was the first embodiment of what
we might call scientific medicine,
was still the dominant medical paradigm
for disease as it had been for nearly
two millennia.
And so our first task will be to examine
a topic and intellectual history of
medicine,
a topic that will help us to understand
how the first epidemic disease that
we're going to study bubonic plague was
understood how it was experienced by
physicians, statesmen,
and educated layman.
And we'll also be in a position then
to understand that epidemic diseases
fundamentally challenged humoral
notions and help to lead toward major
intellectual paradigm shift that
we'll discuss later in the semester.
So our course,
then we'll begin with the legacy of
two of the most influential doctors,
whoever lived both Greeks,
Hippocrates from the fifth century BC
and Galen from the second century of the
common era.
Looking at their philosophy of medicine
will give us a framework to understand
the ways in which the experience
of a plague was a tremendous shock.
Most obviously it was a shock
in terms of death and suffering,
but it was also a shock because it
undermined the foundations of medical and
intellectual understandings of disease.
The passage of bubonic plague through
European society was not only a biological
and material event,
but also a major intellectual,
religious and psychological one.
So having done that next week,
what we'll do is turn to
bluebonnet plague itself.
Now the plague is, everyone's
counted for the worst case scenario.
A plank is synonymous with terror.
One reason was that it was
an extraordinarily rapid
and excruciating killer with
symptoms that were dehumanizing and
agonizing with no effective therapy and to
kill rate that ensured that the
majority of its suffers perished.
It was also readily transmissible so
that it seemed poised at various times to
destroy the whole population of Europe
and it did kill an enormous proportion of
the population up to half
and major European cities.
So here was the origin of a terrifying
cliche about plug that it struck down so
many that there weren't enough
people left to bury the dead.
So what will we do next week?
What we'll look at symptoms of plague,
it's horrifying effects on
the individual human body.
We'll look at its devastating impact on
society and at the responses of whole
populations to the time of plague,
mass flight,
scapegoating, social disorder,
up surges and religion,
new cults of Saints,
new iconographies in the arts,
but there's more to it than not.
The plague led also to the first
successful strategies of public health to
combat pestilence strategies that were
often draconian and direct proportion to
the magnitude of the threat.
These strategies included as we'll see
boards of health with almost unlimited
powers during the emergency quarantine,
military lines and naval blockade to
isolate cities or even whole countries.
And we'll have see pest houses to confine
an isolate the sick and dying and as a
guide to our experience,
we have this book,
which is Daniel Defoe's
journal of a plague gear,
which is the first reading assignment.
And I want to talk about it for a minute
because some of you may want to start
reading it straight away.
I'm not too good as a salesman,
but I do think it's appropriate
to make a plug for great books.
And in this case of default,
I want to introduce one the classics
of a whole genre of what you'll become
familiar with as plague literature.
Defoe's masterpiece is a powerful
description by a contemporary and fact,
a survivor of the most dreadful outbreak
of boob plague and the history of the
British isles.
The catastrophic visitation
of 1665 plagues had returned
in successive waves in
European history ever since the first
visitation of 1347 but one of the terrible
features about it is that over the
centuries it didn't become milder.
And some of its last visitations where
the most violent and horrendous of all,
including the epidemic that ravage London
in 1665 now a possible issue for some
may be overcoming the barrier of language.
So I want to throw out a challenge.
The book I will admit,
can start out a bit
slowly for some of you.
So I want you to think not so much at the
outset as you open it up as to whether
you immediately enjoy it on
though I hoping that you will.
But I want you to think instead
about why it's so important.
I'd like you to think about what you
can learn from being in the company of
someone who had the experience of living
through the worst of all public health
calamities and to ask yourselves why
this book has been read avidly for 400
years.
It may interest you also to know that
during the SARS outbreak in Toronto in
2003 thousands of people were quarantined
in their homes and that the top of
their list of books that they read to
pass the time and make sense of their
experience was this one to foes
journal of the plague gear.
Well,
history after all is in part about sharing
a common culture and common memories
and reading this book.
Then there's certainly part of that and
if you think of it in those ways with
those questions in mind, I think,
and this is my secret agenda,
you'll really enjoy it.
I also think that you'll find it's
a wonderful account of how a society
responded to one of the greatest of all
challenges to recounts the flight of the
King and other authorities from
London in fear for their lives.
He tells us about religious enthusiasm,
about how people understood the
catastrophe they were experiencing,
what it meant to them.
He tells us about the hunt that was on
for witches and scapegoats and culprits.
He talks about plague induced crime,
the helplessness of physicians,
about popular culture and desperate
attempts of people to save themselves.
And then about the extreme measures of
shutting people up in their homes by
government authorities or taking
them away by force to past houses.
And since this is a comparative course,
Oh,
hope that you'll begin to reflect on how
far we've changed and progressed from
the time that differ road. And I'll
draw your attention, for example,
to the early years of the
HIV aids epidemic and we'll
think together about some
possibly very troubling similarities.
In fact,
one of the constants in the centuries
since the plague itself and the West has
been a tendency in times of public health
crises to resort to plague measures of
self defense.
We'll see that very dramatically and
the 19th century and the time of cholera
when the desperate attempt was made to
stop Asiatic cholera with measures that
had worked against plague.
But turned out to be
entirely counterproductive.
And we'll see it again in the
early years of the AIDS pandemic.
And in that case too,
with haunting consequences.
So now you know where we'll begin on
Wednesday with medical science and its
first but long lasting embodiment and
the way that Europeans experience play
through the lens of humoral theory.
And then next week we'll deal with the
most devastating epidemic to strike the
western world, bubonic
plague. And in Daniel Defoe,
you have a really good guide to
accompany you on your journey.
So I'll see you next time.